welcome back to all our viewers this is
Anjali from simply learn so in a
previous video we went through what
loops in Python are and we briefly went
through pol loops while you and Esther
you today will focus solely on pol you
so let's start from scratch and look at
what exactly all you is so for loop is
used to iterate over a sequence now this
sequence could be list topple array
string or even a range of numbers so if
you have multiple elements stored
consecutively for loop is exactly what
you need to access each of those
elements now here is the syntax for pol
you so first you have the keyword for
followed by counter counter is just a
variable which keeps track of the
position of the elements that you are
accessing right now and then you have
the keyword in followed by sequence now
sequence is basically the name of your
list your topple array string or even a
range of integers and then it's followed
by codons and in the very next line you
can put down your statements which come
within the for loop so you better
understand this we have a series of
demos which I will be showing on pycharm
so let's move on to that so our first
demo is a classic example of where you
use for loop that is to access the
elements of a list
so first we'll create our list and leave
my list X and you'll have the elements
14.2 and the strings simply learn now
this particular list of us has just
three elements so we could print the
elements specifying their positions
individually say x comma 0 x comma 1 and
X of 2 so we could print the elements of
a list specifying the indexes
individually so say X of 0 comma X of 1
comma X of 2 and if we run this code
save this and run it
as you see here all the elements are
printed correct but what if our list had
hundred elements this would be quite a
tedious approach then wouldn't it so
here is where you use the for loop it's
for you can have a counter variable
which is I in my case in and this is the
place where you enter your list name so
X : and I'll just see print of I so what
we are doing here is we have this
variable I which is a counter and we
iterate over every element of X so the
first iteration I will hold the value 1
the second iteration I will hold the
value for point two and the third in
both the values simply learn so let's
run this code
and there you go all our elements are
printed so this is a much simpler way to
print the elements of your list now four
can also be used to print every
character in your string separately so
if X is just equal to simply learn and
we run this code once again you see all
the elements of your string are printed
now if you want all of them to be
printed together that is in one line in
your print statement just put end put
two braces and then run this code and
the entire string is printed here but
character by character so we can debug
this to see how its printed just place a
breaking point on your first line and
debug sample
and I'll enlarge my console press f8 to
move from one line to the other and our
first line is executed so X holds the
values simply learn and now we are on a
four loop line the first time we
executed ie takes the value of the very
first character in our string X which is
s so now when we say print of I s gets
printed you go back to a console we can
see this here and next thing we press f8
now I will take the value I from X and I
gets printed in this manner all the
characters of your string are printed
one by one and then your program
terminates so that's the very basic
example of how you can use for loop now
let's try another case where we want to
print all the evil numbers in the range
of 0 to 20 so once again we have 4i
which is a counter variable in now when
you want to specify a range of values
you use a function range and give your
starting value
and your ending value so the thing that
range is guys that if you keep your
ending values 20 it will only consider
the numbers from 0 to 19 but we want 20
also to be included so ending value is
21 here put your colons and let's just
see what this prints first so print of I
and we'll run the school so here the
for-loop printed all the values from 0
up to 20 now we want only e-even values
between 0 to 20 to be printed one way of
doing this is that you can check using
an if statement if every value that is
stored in I is a multiple of 2 or you
can simply modify this range function
slightly and put comma 2 so here what
this means is that every second element
is only printed so 0 will be printed one
would be skipped and then 2 would be
printed let's see that run it so as you
see here in just two lines of code we
got all I even numbers between 0 to 20
printed now say we want to find the sum
of all these even numbers but this time
because you want to use a slightly
different approach
we'll use the if statement to know if
the value in I is even or not so the
first line would be about the same
except you delete the two from the range
and then you have if statement so if I
mod 2 is equal to equal to 0 you will
have a variable say sum which is equal
to sum plus I so what we're doing here
is I will hold a value between 0 to 21
and then this value is tested to check
if it is a multiple of 2 that is if
division by 2 gives any lumen der or not
in the a statement and if it does not
give any remainder that is if the
remainder is 0 then we come in and we
keep adding this I to another variable
which in our case is some so sum is the
addition of all the even numbers now we
have not declared some
yet and some needs to have some initial
value so just outside your for loop with
some equal to zero so here we have added
our even numbers now once this entire
procedures we can print a variable sum
let's run this code and the sum of all
the even numbers between 0 to 20 is 110
now let's move on to our next demo where
we'll be printing patterns so patterns
are a great way to implement for loops
and also to sharpen your programming
skills in a previous video we had a
pattern with Asterix Engels we printed
an inverted triangle using asterisks so
here this is the pattern will be printed
with numbers so for this particular
program will be taking input from the
user
specifying a number so in this example
the number entered by the user would be
5 and as you can see the number given by
the user is the last digit of the last
row also it is a number of rows in the
pattern so let's begin coding this first
we'll take the input from the user in a
variable say n so all the inputs given
by the users always in string format in
case of pipe we need to convert this
into end so input into a number now we
will have the first for loop which is
for every row so for I
in range of 1 to n plus 1 because if we
give in then the range should be taken
only from n to n minus 1 now that's an
outer follow and in case of patterns as
you go through others you notice that
there are at least two for loops even
for the most simple patterns so here is
where we implement nested loops
specifically nested for loops now the
outer for loop as I mentioned earlier is
for the number of rows and will have the
inner for loop for every element in the
row for J in range off again 1 up till
high so when we consider our outer for
loop it goes from 1 then 2 3 4 and then
5 and the inner volume prints from 1 up
till the 8th number now inside our inner
for loop we'll just print J and we do
not want to go to the next line
immediately after printing jail so put
end equal to goats but once we complete
printing the entire row then we want to
move on to the next line so after inner
for loop that is under our outer for
loop we print the new line so just put a
plain print statement here now let's run
this code
enter a number we start with five and as
you can see here 1 1 2 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 has
been printed but the fifth row is not
printed yet so if you go back to your
code you'll see where the error is it's
in this second for you we have run it
from 1 to I and not I plus 1 so what
happened here is that since we learn it
till I when I was 1 the inner volume ran
zero number of times and therefore it's
a first row that was not printed and the
second row printed just one a third row
produces 1 2 and so on so we'll make
this correction and run it again and the
5 and there you go a pattern is printed
let's run it again and try a different
number this time say 10 so a pattern is
printed for any number that you enter
now another very popular application of
nested for-loops
is accessing the elements of a matrix so
here we implement matrix as a list
containing list and what we do is we
take two such lists or two such matrices
from the user and we'll find their sum
so to add two matrices it's very
important that they have the same
dimensions that is they have the same
number of rows and columns so we take
the number of rows and columns from the
user first
and convert this to payment next take
the number of columns maybe even see
you
now we will create our list of first
list which is X right now X is empty
okay so our first for loop will be to
iterate over the elements in our list X
so for I in R because R is the number of
elements in X and C is the number of
elements in the list in X so for I in R
and now are enough for loop so our outer
volume are for the lists in X thus for
the elements in X and the inner volume
will be for the elements within those
lists in X so for J in C so the approach
will be taking is that will first create
those individual lists within X and then
we'll add that list to X so let's name
our inside list as Val and to add
elements to a list use the function
insert now the element would be inserted
in the jth position and E value for the
element would be again taken from the
user so input enter the I into J element
so we'll enter the placeholders to
person that D element
hi comma G so we haven't declared
valuate let's do that initially an empty
list so all the values within our list
value would be inserted within D enough
for you so once we are out of the inner
volume our list valve would be ready so
now we can add this list valve to our
list X so outside here put X dot insert
at position I the insert ban I will
explain this part once again so our
outer for loop for I in R where R is the
number of elements in X that is the
number of lists within our parent list X
would be counted in I and our inner
volume which is for the elements within
our childless would be counted in J and
inside our inner for loop we take the
input from the user
and insert it into our temporary list
Val and then once we exited the inner
for loop we add this list Val to a
parent list X and we are done with
taking the input for the first list now
in the similar manner we take the input
for the second list to rename a second
list Y which is initially empty and you
can just copy paste this code here
change the X to Y and that should do it
now one thing we missed out here is
clearing bad we don't necessarily have
to do this because every time you go
back to the inner for loop and you see
input this value at the J position of
valid the previous value will be
automatically overwritten but still will
clear it every time you exit the inner
poly okay so we are done with taking the
input for both unlist containing lists
and now we move on to the part where we
find their sum so first we create a
variable sum which will be an empty list
now this list will hold the added value
from the other two lists so again for
accessing the elements of a list
containing lists we need nested
for-loops
so for I in our once again and for chi
in c so just like when we took input
when we are finding the sum to will
first add the elements of the child list
so say find the sum of the first list
within X and the first list within y and
once we find the sum of these two lists
we put that into our parent list some so
we'll use Val again for a temporary list
and Val dot insert at the Jade position
the sum of the elements in the j
position of our list in x and y so X of
I J plus y of I J
and once we come out of the inner pol
you that means our pie list is complete
we can add this list to a parent list
some so some dot insert at the eye
position insert val and every time we
exit the inner for loop we also clear
val and that's how you take two lists of
lists from the user find their sum and
finally print it so just print some
let's run this code enter the number of
rows let's start at two number of
columns to okay so we have an error here
for I in R so the error here is our as
an integer and when we want to iterate
over a range of numbers we need to
specify the function range so range of
and and the indices in lists or matrices
start from zero so zero up to R in the
similar way let's make this collection
for all one of four loops zero to C and
here
and here
you
okay let's run the program once again
and now we got to enter elements so our
first element second footer so with that
we completed all the elements of our
first list zero zero element is the
first element in your first list of X
zero one is the is the second element in
your first list 1 0 is the first element
in your second list and 1 1 would be the
second element in your second list all
in X now we start entering the elements
for y the first element of the first
list in Y
so we entered all the elements for both
x and y and this is our list some
but then this is not least some of the
elements what has happened here is that
it's just concatenated the elements of
the two lists so first element in list X
that is one and our first element in
list Y which is two is just concatenated
and it's given 12
whereas we want three the sum of them
this because we took the input from the
user but we forgot to convert it to
eight that means all the elements were
stored in the list as strings and when
we use just the plus sign on strings
it just concatenates the values so now
we convert each of the inputs to integer
and they are inputs are now converted to
integer now we can run the program once
again enter the elements
and this time our sum is printed right
so 1 plus 5 is 6 2 plus 6 is 8 3 plus 7
which is 10 and 4 plus 8 is 12 so now
that you learn how to deal with matrices
or lists containing lists using for
loops let's move on to strings so an X
table would be to find out if the string
entered by the user is a palindrome or
not
so palindrome is a word or phrase or
even a sentence that even when read in
this reverse direction is the same so
for example madame is a palindrome
because if you leave madam in the
reverse direction to if still sees
Madame
similarly the sentence was it a rat I
saw is also a palindrome so now let's
write a program to figure out if the
string enter by the users a palindrome
or not first then we take the input from
the user into a string will store this
in available STG now if your string is a
palindrome that means the first element
of your string is the same as the last
element of your string and the second
element of your string would be the same
as the second last element of your
string and so on so pure string is
madame then as you see M is your first
element and M is your last element a is
your second element and a is your second
last element and in between you have D
so if you want to compare every element
from the first half of your string to
the second half of your string you just
need to run a four loop up till halfway
the length of the string so for I in
range of zero to find the length of the
string we have the Len function 2 which
will pass STG and then we divide this by
2 so we are using two slashes because we
want the integer value not a floating
point value now inside this we'll have
an if statement to check if STG of I is
not equal to STG of Len of SDG - 1 - I
so let me explain the slide to you now
STD of I will give you the element from
the first half of your string and if you
subtract I from the length of the string
you'll get the eighth position element
but from the back of your string so if
we use the same example that is madam s
TG of I would give you M and s TG of I
from the back of the string would also
give you em now length of the string is
always one more then they last in
exposition of your string because the
indices in your string is calculated
from zero and the length is taken from
one so the last position of your string
madam would be poor but the length of
your string madam would be five
therefore we are subtracting one and I
so that we get the I position from the
back of the string I hope that's clear
now now if these two elements are not
the same break out of the for loop
because clearly then it is not a
palindrome string and if it is the same
increment your count by one now count is
available that we need to declare
outside
but I'll tell you why we are using the
count statement after this last if
statement that we put into place so
outside your for loop you have the
escapement when you check it count is
equal to equal to half the length of the
string
now here if your count is equal to half
the length of the string that means
every iteration in four was completed
that is I went right from 0 up to length
of the string / - if count is anything
lesser than this number that means that
the if statement resulted in true
somewhere in between and we broke out of
the for loop because of which I could
not run all the way up to the end and
count was not incremented every time
so if count is equal to half the length
of the string that means that your
string was a palindrome so string was a
so percentile s is a palindrome else
print percentile s is not a palindrome
and there you go so now let's run the
code this is definitely not a palindrome
let's now try it a pallet room so Madame
and I see Madame is a palindrome so
programs working fine let's recheck this
let's try out another word save racecar
and yes race car is also palindrome so
with that we also learn how to use poor
loops in taking care of strings we found
out if a string is a palindrome or not
so there are many other applications of
for loop you can practice a few more and
with that we come to an end of our
tutorial on for loop in Python if you
have any doubts please post them in the
comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you if you like
this video please hit the like button
also subscribe to our channel as we have
a lot more great videos coming up see
y'all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified click
here